Never in my 15 years as a K pop Stan would have
ever guessed I would witness something like this.
I can't get over the fact that the poop terrorist
not only exist,
but they then post it, an apology,
and then offer to pay any laundry fees
to the people who were affected.
Aka got the poop on them.
Then the fact that Kpop idols were visibly gagging
over the poop air.
Same girl, same.
And the fact that the pooping incident was not the
only thing to allegedly happen at this award show.
And supposedly people were doing the dupe to dupe
and dupes were found. Yuck.
And allegedly a fight broke out
and 80s in their personal staff had to do crowd control.
People also said that 80s staff help with cleaning up
the FECAL matter on the ground
and my gosh,
they need to be compensated.
Update update update.
So apparently allegedly this was a planned poop attack.
The person who claims to be the poop standing toilet
aka the poop terrorist
has a history of talking about poop in
and all those other stuff.
And they said that they wanna
take it out of the bathroom.
I. I don't know,
but this is what people are saying
and I did my research and this is on their account.
And my question is,
is this not biological warfare?